well the la rams uh one of the teams
that
is not in the top 10 in this week's
final regular season pft power rankings
we posted on tuesday we talked about
them here on wednesday with some of your
input
your questions and for the second
straight week the buffalo bills
do you feel differently this week about
the bills as the potential number one
team i mean the chiefs
the chiefs called off the dogs they they
rested players patrick mahomes didn't
play they lost to the chargers
but i i was so impressed by what the
bills did against the dolphins team that
was trying to get to the playoffs
and to hang 56 on the number one scoring
defense in the nfl
and and the hesitation to take out the
starters i really do think sean
mcdermott is aware of the fact that
they've got their
their foot on the gas not at a red light
in a drag race setting but
but they they're afraid to take it off i
i think so too
i think you're exactly right i mean you
got to go and you got your mojo going
you know we've seen a lot of teams
through history
kind of go through the kind of stretch
they're going where
okay maybe you'll lose a game around
week 9 10 or 11
and all sudden you go on this run and
you had to play it out through the
playoffs and that continues
and you never lose a game for the rest
of the season i mean that's gone on a
lot
through through nfl's history those kind
of runs so i understand that
and to your question yes that made me
think differently
i mean we were already thinking
differently
but like you said it i would nobody can
get in the end zone against the miami
dolphins
they're the kings of making you kick
field goals and buffalo made it look
like
56 no problem we could score 86 if we
want today
that's not an issue that was extremely
impressive
both sides of the football the bills and
the packers
i think made me think differently about
those two teams more than any two teams
down the
down the month of december the packers
you know my thoughts i i think you were
there with me where i went
ah they're good i'm just not sold it's a
lot of roger's magic
to where the last few weeks i've gone
man defense seems tougher and grittier
offense seems to run it and do whatever
it wants now and i just look at both of
them and go
i wouldn't be shocked if we saw a
packers bill super bowl they're both
kind of
kicking butt yeah and and the
chiefs have shown that they can get it
done in january
that's the key how much of december
carries over
into january where you know entering the
game and throughout the entirety of the
contest that if you lose
you are done playoff experience is
critical
dealing with adversity in the postseason
is critical
this is where we make that shift from
regular season 5
to postseason vibe and i remember rodney
harrison explaining this to me years ago
that everything changes in the playoffs
it's faster it's more intense
and the guys who haven't been there
before are the ones who are more likely
to freak out in the moment the guys who
have been there and done that
they understand how it is and when you
look at what the chiefs did last year
down 24
to the texans down 10 twice in the first
half of the titans down 10 with seven
minutes left
in the super bowl they are not going to
freak out in the moment
and they probably like the fact that
guys like us
are saying how great the bills are right
now because
sure that gives them a reason to have a
little chip on their shoulder going into
the postseason and when the top dog has
the chip on its shoulder it's far more
dangerous
it's definitely more dangerous we're not
forgetting of them at all
i mean definitely not they're still the
kings of the hill
they still have the ability to make more
magic than any other team we've seen in
football and rise to you know the
challenge the occasion whatever it may
be
so uh i'm i'm not forgetting about them
and hey they needed this rest they
needed to take a little last week off
you know you said it all year they were
hunted this year
it's not easy you play a long season
last year
you have a weird off season you know and
then
everybody is gunning for you week after
week after week and you constantly have
to kind of be on your a
plus a game be ready to go answer the
bell
it wore them out and you could see it
and they needed to get healthy and i
think mentally
you know refreshed and all those type of
things so uh
that's why i'm excited about the
playoffs because we got some teams that
are
peaking at the right time and of course
we get the chiefs who are amazing
we've got the odds from points bet of
uh nfl champion possibilities the
various teams at the top
let's come up with a loose list of of
who we
have the most confidence in right now of
all the teams
in the postseason field who do you
believe
is the most likely to win the super bowl
are these odds accurate
the chief's the favorite at plus 220. i
i think so
i i think that's ex i see it that way at
kansas city
you know again i'm with you like the
bills are right there with the chiefs
like i said last week
i'd still if we the chiefs and bills
play tomorrow i'm taking the chiefs even
though i think the bills are playing a
little bit better
i got to see that magic of kansas city
squashed one time
before i pick against them every time
they need it they make it happen so
i do go with them i've actually i you
know in front of me right here yeah i
wrote green bay is number two
and then i wasn't sure with bills and
saints that was where
i have an arrow going each way and i
don't know who do you feel more
well obviously you feel more comfortable
about buffalo right now right the new
orleans
yeah look if i was doing these odds i
would go kansas city first then buffalo
i i know that buffalo's major impediment
is the chiefs
but i i just i feel better about
the bills beating the chiefs than any
team from the nfc beating the chiefs
right sure so why wouldn't the bills be
higher than the packers and the saints
on the list of odds to win the super
bowl so when i see that i think well if
i was betting on this
i'd like the bills at plus 750 because i
think that one's off and i like the
bucks
at plus 1000 not that i would put them
you know
ridiculously high on the list of teams
most likely to win but plus 1 000 sounds
pretty good because i think the
buccaneers are the one team in the nfc
that could win the super bowl if they
can get there
sure challenge is getting there it's
going to be hard to get there i think
when they get there
two weeks to prepare with tom brady i
think that they
they could they could give the afc
champion more of a run for their money
than the other teams in the nfc so
you've got kansas city green bay then
buffalo
i i think i would go kansas city green
bay
and then buffalo barely over the saints
i mean buffalo is where they are
i think just because of one reason lack
of experience right
everybody wants to see at least on the
you know the uh the points bet thing
the points bet line there i think that's
the reason they're really to answer your
question
you know the saints are ahead of it
because hey it's drew brees it's you
know aaron rodgers there's guys who have
been there and done that
we haven't seen buffalo do that yet so
i'm sure that's you know
hindering them as far as gambling is
concerned but i would probably put the
bills
slightly ahead of the saints right now
but i don't feel really really
comfortable about that i think saints
pre
you know last few playoff struggles drew
brees not exactly making plays in the
playoffs and doing things like that that
scares me a little bit and that's why i
do give the bills the advantage
yeah my top five now that we've we've
thought this through and talked this
through a little bit
are bills then no i'm sorry chiefs then
bills
then buccaneers then packers okay
and i don't know
ravens before saints ravens before
saints
ravens are too hot right now and the
ravens are the team that can screw
everything up
and they've got the attitude that we're
going to come screw everything up
that's the thing what what they've that
that
that mindset that they've developed over
the last five weeks where it's just been
we have to win we have to win we have to
win we have to win they've built this
bullet that's going to show up and kick
your butt
that's what i'm concerned about for
these other teams that they're going to
be the potential disrupter
and even though they don't have a lot of
playoff experience
i don't think they care at this point
it's line up and kick your butt
line up and kick your butt so i would
even i
the thing with the saints and i'm
impressed the saints keep getting back
to the playoffs
yeah after having their hearts ripped
out every year but now we're back in
that mode
where they are accustomed to having
their hearts ripped out i don't know how
they reverse that
it's three straight years of having
their hearts ripped out and how do you
erase from your being from your mind
from your soul from anywhere in your
body
the notion that here it comes again
it's gonna happen again it's it just
keeps happening when we get into this
single elimination
atmosphere so i that's and and the other
issues with the saints the injuries and
michael thomas and alvin kamara
and and the drew brees deep ball and
it just feels like for as good as
they've been this year it just feels
like something's a little bit off
i i mean i'm here i hear you i think
that's why i i put them forth because of
those questions you know
i do you know but their defense is
phenomenal
i think they are one of those teams that
could upset things too in the nfc
obviously i i do you know when you have
an offensive line like that you can run
the football the way they do
the way their defense is played really
down the stretch
they're still very very scary football
team
definitely so but but i think i'm chiefs
packers bills saints
and then this is where i i'm stuck
between the bucks and the ravens right
now
with the seahawks being the team that
comes after those two right there
i think i'm with you though i think i
have a little more trust in the bucks
uh than the ravens and i'm gonna go
bucks there as my number five raven six
seahawks sevens that's kind of how i
would feel as far as my chris sims
comfort tree
i may put the seahawks ahead of the
saints i'm sorry saints i hate to do
this wow but i may i'm just thinking
i'm thinking you put them on a field
together now jamal adams is going to be
a huge factor in that big factor shorter
injury that may or may not allow him to
play this weekend
but the seahawks have that exp you've
got you've got a quarterback
who's a hall of famer with two super
bowls under his belt
and playoffs playoff playoffs almost
every year you've got a coach who's been
there and done that
i i do you know every year we have to
remind ourselves
don't overlook the value of extensive
postseason experience sure brady is the
king of it
but when we look at these other teams
over the years
and and high level of achievement you
you've got
the the the seahawks are number two you
think it's the saints
but the seahawks have been to two super
bowls the saints have been to one
and they've got the same coach in the
same quarterback and a lot of the other
same
guts of the organization the players
have changed dramatically obviously
but i i think there's there's value in
that for both the seahawks and the
saints no i agree
i think there's more recent battle tests
you know tested factors maybe in seattle
even though it's been a few years yes uh
but there's
you know bobby wagner and kj wright
russell wilson who were there for it all
you know who still understand that
there's nobody left of that new orleans
team that won the super bowl back then
except for drew brees and sean payton
that's all there is to it but i i still
think their experience their toughness
their grittiness
they match up very well with chicago uh
i i still think they're gonna
have something to be said here i would
not be shocked if we were sitting there
championship sunday and the new orleans
saints were involved in that football
game
the nfc in general i just look at that
and go
a few weeks ago i think i would have
gone oh the afc is clearly better than
the nfc
but when you really talk about in my
opinion the top four teams in the nfc
which would be green bay new orleans
seattle and tampa bay
i think they have closed the gap and i'm
not so sure their top four teams aren't
better than the top four teams of the
afc now where we sit
and how those teams are playing right
now because i'm not going to put a
like pittsburgh in tennessee yeah i got
questions about them yeah buffalo and
kansas city were good
but man tennessee i i think you and me
could go out there and put up 30 points
on offense against that defense
so that's a little that's a little no
probably not but that's that's what
position would i be playing uh
i uh um we'd have to make you automatic
snapper
i think that was what we have to do
automatic snapper and then have
bodyguards next to you to make sure you
don't get run over thanks
thank you so much but i don't know that
was how i feel a little yeah go ahead
that was the question that sweetness
posed via twitter now that the regular
season is over how does the fc stack up
against the nfc
and and here's the other side of it too
by the time you have the afc champion
face the nfc champion there will be more
games that have been played
teams will feel better about themselves
that idea of being the one who emerges
from the cluster you know
if i don't know how much better the
chiefs will feel about themselves if
they emerge but i could see the
nfc champion having some extra swagger
confidence belief going into the super
bowl by way of
of navigating this play off especially
if you win a game or two on the road if
you're the buccaneers and you go
to lambeau field and beat the packers
maybe in the championship game to punch
your ticket
to the super bowl played in your home
stadium that's the one factor we can't
overlook and that's why i feel better
about the buccaneers on this
on this list of who we think is most
likely to win the super bowl if the
buccaneers get there
they're staying at home all week they're
staying at home
they're in their facility they're there
and i know that the travel
realities will have the other teams
there too but i'm talking about in your
stadium in your place
in your habitat i think that's a huge
advantage for the buccaneers if they end
up getting to the super bowl chris
i don't disagree with that you know yes
anytime
you don't have to leave your comfort
zone that's always a positive as a
football player
to be able to be in your facility super
bowl two weeks basically
and and and just feel like i get to come
home to my house my bed do all
that that is a great advantage my only
thing i would go like
because as you were talking there i was
going wait was there any negative to
that
the only negative i would think would
just be like maybe
it doesn't feel as special because
you're at home but
i don't know if really that's that's a
thing that was the only negative aspect
i could come up with
well it's not going to feel special for
the other team though either because the
other yeah it's going to stay where they
are yeah
it's treated like a road game in tampa
if if the teams that make it to the
super bowl and obviously the afc
representative
will be treating it as a road game to
tampa if it's any of the other teams in
the nfc other than tampa
same deal it's like you're playing at
tampa so it's not going to be
like it is in any other year other than
the game but even for the game it's not
going to be like it is any other year
because there's not going to be a full
stadium
of fans speaking of the buccaneers mike
ness 18 has a question for us
is this current buccaneers team looking
as good as the team that john gruden
assembled when the bucks won the super
bowl in early 2003.
your thoughts on how these buccaneers
compare to the buccaneers that you know
very well because you joined them
in the immediate aftermath of winning
that super bowl yes i i think that this
buccaneers team
and this offense is is far more
explosive you know
just with brady evans gronk a.b godwin
all of that i mean
wow it's just this is a they've gotten
to a point here the last few weeks where
you just i go i don't know if you can
really stop them
i don't i think it's them messing up is
what you have to hope for a little bit
and they're the way brady's playing and
everything like that so the offense
clearly better
now defense you know no i i can't say
that i mean that was an all-time defense
that's one of the greatest defenses in
the history of football right there
tampa bay buccaneers with warren sapp
and derek brooks and rondae
barber and john lynch and simeon rice
holy cow
they could win games by themselves as
you saw
and the super bowl they almost did that
to a degree
stopping one of the greatest offenses
ever so i don't think i'm ready to rank
them there quite yet
but i think the real thing is and you
just said it
they have super bowl champion potential
that's the real thing and we'll see if
they can kind of keep their hot streak
going here through the playoffs
we talked earlier about the seahawks
mike on twitter has a question if the
offense plays like it did earlier in
this year
are the hawks the favorites in the nfc
that's a big if
i think for the offense to do what it
was doing back in the days of let russ
cook which feels like it was a different
season not just a different month but if
they could get that magic back i don't
know if they want to get that magic back
i don't know if they're trying to get
that magic back
but given where the defense currently is
if all of a sudden they're throwing it
all over the place if they were
you know doing a little rope-a-dope and
they switched to southpaw and now
they're going to switch back
if they could have that kind of impact
offensively yeah they would be very
dangerous wouldn't they
yeah definitely i mean they need they've
definitely lost their swagger on the
offensive side of the ball that's for
sure
you know not that they need to like you
know put up 40 points and
and throw it 50 times a game because
you're right like you know
what you're saying they don't want to
really do that they want to
you know play a little bit of balance
football and make real
have russell make some big plays in the
past game now they've they've struggled
a little bit that way
they have to find some ways to make
things a little easier on the offensive
side of the ball
too much of the offense at this moment
is just like hey russell
we need you to make something happen run
game not really kicking butt
can't say there's consistently open
receivers they need to do more there
uh and that's kind of the worry it's
crazy it's crazy
it's why pete carroll i mean he deserves
to be in the coach of the year
conversation too with
just the hell what he's done with that
defense this year i mean they were
on pace to be one of the worst in the
history of football
and then here the last five or six weeks
i believe they're second
in football in almost every statistical
category on defense
behind the the los angeles rams
phenomenal transformation but i do think
the offense
has got to play at a little higher level
than they had as of late if they want to
make a run here in the playoffs
here's a question from hawktoberfest why
are the steelers
lower than the ravens when the ravens
lost to the steelers
twice this year and oktoberfest all i'll
tell you is this
right now if the ravens and the steelers
crossed paths
it would not be 3-0 for the pittsburgh
steelers that's why the ravens are
higher
right now than the steelers chris do you
agree with that assessment i do i
i mean i think the ravens are going in
the playoffs as one of the hottest teams
in the game
so and yes like pittsburgh to me is one
of the most fascinating stories going on
in the playoffs
you know with big ben you know is he 100
healthy
and then they played one
good half of football and
that's the only good half of football
they played in the month of december on
the offensive side of the ball
so i'm just i am what i can't wait for
in our game sunday night is just
like what offense are we going to see
from pittsburgh
where is this going to go and i don't
think you could sit here and confidently
say you think they're going to execute
better than the ravens and some of the
teams you got in front of them right now
so i'm with you i hear you i think
you're totally justified as far as
having the ravens in front of them
one thing that was lost in all of the
outcomes and action on sunday mason
rudolph actually played
pretty well we didn't expect much so
when you set the bar low it's easy to
say we
we think he played well but he actually
did play well so if big ben
would end up uh having to come out
it's it's not as disastrous right as we
thought it would have been they still
need to rediscover their running game
though
you can't win in january without a
running game and they're going to have
to come out and run the ball they get an
advantage though
with everything that's happening with
the browns this should be a game the
steelers win
and then the question becomes can they
go to buffalo assuming that the bills
beat the colts
can they go to buffalo and pull off a
victory there in the divisional round we
saw what happened to the steelers in
buffalo on a sunday night a few weeks
ago
last question before we break as it
relates to the eagles dr j144
the eagles are number 29 in the final
power rankings the question is this
where would the eagles be if they had
started nate sunfeld all 16 games
i think we know i think we do know from
what we saw right there and well listen
they
knew that's what like that's what's they
knew
i mean come on they knew exactly what
they were gonna get out of there they
would be 32
probably i i think that's fair to say
certain certainly
they would be contemplating what to do
with carson owens and jalen hurts and
nate sudfeld because there would be a
new sheriff in town
and his name would be trevor lawrence hi
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports